hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about intermittent fasting and what is
the science behind it and at the end of
this video we'll get to know what are
the myth versus what is the reality so
stay tuned till the end of this video
intermittent fasting is an eating
pattern that cycles between period of
fasting and period of eating so simply
in your feeding pattern in a day you
would have a window which is so called
feeding window where you can eat
and there would be a fasting window
where you can't simply eat or you fast
now it doesn't specify which food you
should be eating
or which calories you should be taking
but it really implies that when you
should eat that so it doesn't have any
restriction of a specific type of food
in the feeding window you can consume
all the food and that's pretty
beneficial right you can enjoy carbs you
can enjoy protein and fat everything
but in the fasting window you cannot
intake any of carbohydrate protein or
fat and you have to strictly follow that
fasting window
now let me tell you that how
intermittent fasting works
and does intermittent fasting cause
weight loss and if it does weight loss
then how and what are the health
benefits of intermediate fasting
so let's quickly look at the health
benefits you would have a increased
growth hormone secretion while you're
fasting for long
it reduces inflammation improves your
cognitive abilities
it also controls blood glucose level and
it lowers the insulin level
ultimately the biggest achievement from
intermediate fasting is the weight loss
that's pretty assured lastly
it has some anti-aging effects as well
if followed properly now let us
understand what really happens when we
are fed versus we are fasted
when we are fed in our liver glucose is
present in plenty amount
glucose would be converted to glucose
6-phosphate and intermediate ultimately
it would form it would be forming
pyruvate
another intermediate
ultimate goal is to
run that tca cycle and generate energy
which is important for our physical
performance
now
when we are
fasting
let's see what happens but before that
let me tell you
when we have too much of glucose then we
really don't need to get
a lot of energy because we have
sufficient energy in our body then body
stores that excess amount of glucose in
glycogen
later on
it can use the glucose to channel into
pentose phosphate pathway
and generate nadph which further helps
in other anabolic pathways such as fatty
acid biosynthesis
but in fasted state
glucose is low
right and in that condition
we won't be having a lot of uh tca cycle
going right
but body cannot perform without glucose
especially our brain cannot right so in
that circumstances the glycogen which
was stored in the liver would be broken
down
and it would form glucose
later on several intermediates of tca
cycle would be also
generate pyruvate and ultimately glucose
would be produced that would be used by
the brain
now if we fast for very long
then fatty acid would be broken down and
it would generate ketone bodies
that would work like an alternative fuel
so let us try to understand the timeline
of these events that i talked about
so this is the starting point of your
fasting
then immediately what would happen is
there would be glycogenolysis your
stored glucose reserves would be broken
down and glucose would be utilized to
fuel your body
then eventually neo-glucogenesis would
happen
this is a process where body makes
glucose from non-glucose sources so it
would break down
amino acids or it can also take other
intermediates of krebs cycle and channel
it to form glucose
after all of these
like after 12 hour of these events
ketogenesis would start
and if we went further then autophagy
would occur autophagy is a self
recycling process where body recycles
its own organelles
or several cell types and that's pretty
good and autophagy is important aspect
of anti-aging property
now
let us look at what really happens
during intermediate fasting
first of all there would be
glycogenolysis there would be
gluconeogenesis eventually all of that
lead to production of glucose
but when we fast for longer
ultimately ketone bodies such as
acetoacetate acetone or beta
hydroxybutyrate would be produced
and that can fuel our brain during this
prolonged fasting period
even if brain doesn't have the supply of
glucose it has alternative fuel ketone
bodies so simply ketone bodies in the
fasted state work like reserve fuel
now
in this first aid state
the significant effect is the fat
breakdown
in the adipose tissues fat would be
broken down
and that fat would generate acetyl-coa
this acetyl-coa would be utilized for
ketogenesis or production of ketone
bodies because we know in the fasted
state ketone bodies are the key
resources to fuel our body and the way
this resource is generated is by
breaking down of fat
so you can imagine what's the end result
is
your body would start burning fat and
eventually you would be thinner right
let's try to understand the
molecular mechanism behind it let's say
we are at a stub state
in this situation our atp level is low
because atp production is not happening
and amp level is high
our body sense this atp amp ratio and
there are specific sensing mechanisms
such as ampk one particular kinase
enzyme which can sense this aspect
now ampk is basically the master
regulator of catabolism you can imagine
when body is fasting catabolism is very
important because
what you need to break down whatever it
has stored and tried to generate energy
so ampk would immediately inhibit
or inhibit other master regulators for
anabolism master regulator for anabolism
is mdor
so obviously ampk blocks mtor and
thereby stops anabolism
and under circumstances of fasting it's
really important because we can't
produce new stuff we have to break the
existing stuff and try to get energy
from it right
ampk
in several steps and with interact
interaction with several interactors
ensures the genes that help in
ketogenesis or other fasted fasting
related responses are transcribed so
obviously we understand that there are
molecular sensors in our body which can
understand the nutrition input and they
can act accordingly overall ampk can
also generate
proteins which help in fat
oxidation or fat breakdown
okay this might be difficult for
understanding but let me tell you you
are running short of money but you still
have to pay your bills so what you're
going to do
two things
immediately you are going to stop
saving right
and you are going to break your savings
to pay bills
and at this scarcity situation you are
not going to save right so these are the
two things that our body does
it stop producing new molecule and it
breaks down fat which was existing in
the body and try to utilize that in
order to generate energy and run the
body
so
next
another aspect of
intermittent fasting is it helps to
lower the insulin levels you must be
thinking what's the benefit of that
now insulin is a key hormone that allows
glucose uptake into several tissues like
glucose uptake into muscle glucose
uptake into the adipose tissue but
beside these role insulin has another
important function insulin is a master
regulator of anabolism as well so
insulin helps the body to make fatty
acids and eventually this fatty acid is
stored in form of fat and you grow fat
so insulin
insulin level determines the anabolic
status so if you can lower the insulin
level it is good for the body
now let us try to understand this thing
in a detailed fashion
so let's say you have two situation face
fasting and feeding
now when we are in a fasted state we'll
see what happens but before that let's
try to understand when we are fade state
what is really happening
now in the fade state one enzyme known
as acetyl coa carboxylase whose name is
not at all important but this enzyme
helps in fatty acid biogenesis fatty
acid biogenesis
now this enzyme can remain in two
alternative form inactive form or active
form
the switch from inactive to active form
is triggered by
several phosphates enzyme
and kinase enzyme do the other way
around it inhibits the enzyme
now whenever we have
too much glucose in our blood supply
there are plenty of acetyl coa which is
surplus not required for producing
energy so it could work like a raw
material to generate fat moreover
glucose elevates the insulin level in
our body
secondly insulin
triggers these phosphatase enzyme and
ultimately
activates
this
acetyl-coa carboxylase enzyme so
as a combination of these effects
our body produces more fat
and
we can see fat deposition in our body
now when we are
fasting this enzyme does not get
activated instead
kinase enzymes work and inactivate
the acetyl-coa carboxylase
in fasted state glucagon level is high
and insulin level is low
so glucagon
in a particular signaling pathway
activates kinase enzyme that inhibits
fatty acid biogenesis
so it makes sense because under fasted
state
we can't generate more fat our body
would tend to break the fat instead of
storing fat
so what we learned so far is very simple
body do not make fat under starved state
and body
uh utilizes existing fat
and break down that fat to generate
ketone bodies which can serve as an
alternative source as a result you
become thin you lose a lot of fat
so what we understood from overall
discussion
is acetyl coa comes
from the fatty acid breakdown under a
fasted state and
in the fastest state our body needs to
run and perform properly so
in that state
instead of
fueling our body with glucose body
generates ketone bodies which can work
like a reserve
now you must be amused to understand
that we are not the first thing first
people to do this intermediate fasting
paradigm actually human ancestor had
restricted feeding and prolonged fasting
period because they kind of get their
animals or hunting
once in a while and they might have a
period where they don't have any food so
obviously they are fasting and their
body is undergoing a repeated feeding
and fasting cycle so unknowingly they
used to
do intermittent fasting
and these kind of intermittent fasting
paradigms are present in many religious
cultures for example in
islamic
ramadan month they fast and feed in a
specific time window
in hindu culture it is also present
along with christian judaism and many
other cultures
now you must be thinking now that okay
intermittent fasting is good but is
there any restriction in the feeding
window while doing intermittent fasting
yes this is the most important question
now unlike keto diet you don't have any
restriction
you can get
or consume all the food that you want
your calories can come from carbs
protein or even fat doesn't matter but
it is always recommended that we should
fill our stomach with healthy stuff for
example if we consume omega-3 fatty acid
as
a fat
let's say we consume lots of vegetable
and fruits as a source of carbohydrate
and vitamins
then it's always good for our body
now omega-3 fatty acid has tons of
health benefits all these vegetables
would provide us with vitamins and other
macros and micros so that is how you can
really get added benefit in this
intermittent fasting
paradigm
but the best results are obtained when
we avoid processed or too much oily food
but once in a while you can taste those
popcorn hot dog or tasty burgers it
won't really break the paradigm unlike
the keto diet
that is why intermittent fasting is time
restricted feeding where you can enjoy
sometimes your favorite food
and that's the biggest advantage of
intermittent fasting
now intermittent fasting is proved to
increase your cardiac health
it also reduce inflammation it reduce
the chances of having cancer it in
reduce joint inflammation and pain
it is
good for focusing and cognitive
cognitive improvement lastly it is also
good for pregnant women
now when we start intermittent fasting
we should do a gradual step-wise uh
practice first of all let's say we have
a 14 hours of feed feeding and 10 hours
of fasting window
we would increase the fasting window
gradually next we can have a 12 hours of
fasting 12 hours of feeding
eventually in order to get optimal
result we can get 8 hours of feeding and
16 hours of fasting window
so the closing of feeding window
or minimizing the feeding video window
and maximizing the fasting window is a
gradual process the biggest mistake is
doing it dramatically so
body would not be responding well if
this change is drastic body might have
other side effects for that but the best
way to adapt intermittent fasting
is this following this stepwise fashion
where body
is
adapting to these kind of new time
restricted feeding paradigm and it would
give you optimal results
lastly while you are fasting you can
have
other drinks such as green tea coffee or
let's say water
which doesn't have any calories to it
but staying hydrated is really important
for
any kind of fasting
now
the biggest mistake people do is putting
a little bit of sugar in their coffee or
uh the
green tea and that's absolutely wrong
because you're in taking calories and
breaking your fast actually so
intermittent fasting overall is really
important
and it is difficult to follow and you
should always consult a nutritionist or
dietitian for that now let's break some
facts and myths regarding
intermittent fasting first of all people
think intermittent fasting would cause
muscle loss but it's not really true
because it has been shown that
intermittent fasting can increase your
growth hormone level so that means you
can lose fat without losing your muscle
mass
second people think that intermittent
fasting can cause brain dysfunction
because your glucose level would be low
you cannot function without sugar etc
etc but this is not true because once
ketone bodies such as
beta-hydroxybutyrate goes into the brain
it can be broken down and utilized to
generate energy so beta-hydroxybutyrate
eventually in a step-wise fashion
produce acetyl-coa and
koa is utilized
in the krebs cycle to generate energy
brain doesn't care where it gets the
acetyl-coa from whether the acetyl-coa
is
produced from from
pyruvic acid or that acetyl coa is
coming from a ketone body
our brain doesn't care at the moral of
the story brain needs that acetyl coa
for get going and that happens when we
have ketone bodies in our system in
prolonged fasting period so
it should not create dizziness in our
brain or
any other aspects of
brain malfor malfunction should not
occur
now recent research has shown and the
link is provided in the description that
ketone bodies are
prolonged fasting in an intermediate
intermittent fasting paradigm can
improve your
um
cognitive ability so now in this video
we passed all those myths so i hope
you enjoyed this video many other videos
are provided in this channel which would
be good for your knowledge if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can follow me in instagram
and you can follow me on facebook as
well my id is provided here
and
don't forget to
let me know how you like this video in
the comment please comment guys thank
you